nos dicen en la figura de arriba el
triángulo abc es isósceles es decir el
triángulo abc este gran triángulo
isósceles lo que significa que dos de
sus lados son congruentes tienen la
misma longitud aunque no es justo lo que
nos explican es decir el lado ave tiene
la misma longitud que el lado ps estos
dos lados en azul tienen la misma
longitud el triángulo de f
efe se superpone con el triángulo abc
podemos verlo claramente ya que forman
este tipo de estrella de david inclinada
cuál es el valor de p
bien vamos a trabajar juntos a bs es un
triángulo isósceles los dibujaré por acá
de manera separada
y en un triángulo isósceles como en
estos dos de sus lados son congruentes y
por lo tanto dos ángulos son congruentes
además nos dicen que este otro ángulo
tiene 100 grados y sabemos que la suma
de todos los ángulos internos de un
triángulo suman 180 grados si decimos
que este ángulo tiene x grados por lo
tanto este otro también tiene x grados
entonces x + x + 100 es igual a 180 o 2x
es igual y si restamos 100 de ambos
lados me quedara igual a 80 ó x igual a
40 de esta manera podemos resolver que
ambos ángulos son de 40 grados esto lo
obtuvimos de la idea de que abc es un
triángulo isósceles entonces estos dos
ángulos serán congruentes
este ángulo es de 40 grados y este otro
ángulo también es de 40 grados
ahora vamos a fijarnos en este pequeño
triángulo una vez más sabemos que la
suma de esos ángulos internos debe de
ser igual a 180 grados necesitamos
obtener este ángulo de aquí que sabemos
que tiene grados ya que son opuestos por
un vértice el ángulo de grados es
opuesto por el vértice a este ángulo
interno que queremos encontrar y por lo
tanto son iguales así que este ángulo
mide p grados y ahora podemos decir que
p más 40 más 60 deben sumar 180 ya que
son los ángulos internos de este pequeño
triángulo o podemos decir que p más y si
sumamos 40 60 obtenemos 100 p más 100 es
igual a 180 y si restamos 100 de ambos
lados obtenemos que p es igual a 80
grados si este ángulo tiene grados
entonces el valor de p que nos preguntan
es 80